all right Guardians don't forget this
might be dangerous so let's put on our
mean faces
what happened
my wipers get it off
pumps this dude still alive he is not a
dude
Nura dude this this is a man my handsome
muscular man catotti metal fibers stop
massaging his muscles way come on
[Music]
are you guys
everybody is Charlie I've been getting a
lot of requests to do a Thoris in sin
Finiti war came out in there two things
going on with Thor in this movie one he
proves that he works perfectly with the
guardians of the galaxy
so really hoping they cross those
franchises over in the future if the
future of Marvel is those types of
crossover movies like Hulk in a Thor
movie even though technically it's
supposed to be a Thor movie he's the
only one that has his name in the title
like you put Thor in the guardians of
the galaxy movie it would be perfect he
worked amazing with his rabbit he was
there beautiful pirate Angel Drax
totally got along with them if they're
gonna cycle the Guardians roster it
makes sense that they would try to add
Thor into the mix at some point but if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos this is just the beginning of
when we start talking about phase four
we're still kind of an infinity war
right now most of you have probably seen
it by now there is a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway going on too
but I think the biggest questions that
most people had is how does Stormbreaker
work in what have they changed from the
comics because even if you're a minor
comic book reader you probably know that
Stormbreaker is beta ray Bill's hammer
in the comics it's just meant to be a
normal hammer that Odin makes for him
after he's able to defeat Thor in combat
so he decides wow beta ray bill you beat
someone who is normally worthy that
means you're worthy to you deserve your
own hammer so for the most part beta ray
bill Stormbreaker has the same
properties as Thor's hammer like he
could still call lightning lately
they've been doing a lot of weird stuff
with Authority mix we learned that
Mjolnir is actually alive it has this
sentient cosmic storm that Odin bound to
it but now in the movies through Thor's
storyline we learned the origin of his
hammer and how it got its special
properties and how Odin enchants it with
I know a lot of new questions now about
who's worthy is Groot worthy if he can
pick up storm breaker and create the
handle like he actually holds it up for
a little while before he chops his arm
off to form the handle so we're all the
way back at age of Ultron is the
elevator worthy if the elevator can rise
while the Hammers on top of it but if
you put the hammer in an elevator we
still go up elevators not worthy I'm
gonna miss these little talks of Oz so
just to be clear this is the movies
doing their version of Stormbreaker
it's more like ultimate Thor's hammer
though which is basically
just an ax version of Mjolnir it's
called ultimate Mjolnir in the comics so
what they've done is they've combined
that with Stormbreaker from the comics
to create Thor Stormbreaker in the MCU
so yes it has all the same properties as
Mjolnir had now the enchantment is a
little bit different
Odin is the one that used his own magic
to say only the worthy can lift Mjolnir
the difference with Stormbreaker as Thor
explains to the guardians because once
rocket hears about the crazy weapons the
Thor plans on building he's all about it
he's like I want to get me one of those
and the explainer reads a lot like the
rules for who is powerful enough to
wield Infinity stones without being
turned to ash
so remember during the original
guardians of the galaxy you have one of
the collectors servants grab her bare
hand around the Power Stone it's so
powerful that in wielding it it pops her
like a balloon star-lord is half
celestial which is why he's able to hold
it for a little while so even though
he's not immortal anymore he could
probably still hold on to one of the
Infinity stones the way he did during
the first guardians film is that he
doesn't have his crazy cosmic abilities
Thor tells them that the hammer is so
powerful that if you weren't a God like
he is or didn't have his power level and
you tried to wield it it would slowly
drive you insane what your brain melted
inside your head so that's sort of the
defense mechanism it's probably
physically very heavy naturally so one
you'd have to be kind of strong to lift
it anyway but in order to be able to
wield its power you would have to have
some sort of cosmic level ability which
is where Thor is so like if Captain
Marvel came along maybe she could pick
it up maybe she could wield it because
she's going to be wielding cosmic power
the reason why Groot is probably able to
pick it up is one because they do want
to imply that he's kind of worthy but I
think the idea is is the hammer hasn't
been fully activated until Thor wields
his power through it remember when
there's lightning that's Thor giving the
lightning off not the hammer itself the
hammer is only something to channel his
power so it's like Mjolnir with the knob
turned to 11 but also has so much power
that it can open wormholes wielding the
power of the Bifrost this sort of like
the x-factor so the weapon itself is
stronger than Mjolnir but it also has
that extra level of ability which is how
Thor will now travel across the universe
meaning that it'll be a lot easier for
them during Avengers 4 to go back to the
Dwarven Forge and get more weapons if
they need to or if they need to reforge
another Infinity Gauntlet because they
still have the mold there
so if Shuri decides that she needs some
extra hardcore weapons that they can't
make in Wakanda the Dwarven space Forge
is the next best option but you have to
remember that vibranium is supposed to
be the strongest metal on earth there's
a big long-standing argument in the
comics about whether or not dwarf in
forged guru metal is also as strong as
vibranium they're relatively similar so
because they're so near the vibranium
Mound
I wouldn't be surprised if a lot of the
upgrades they get at the beginning of
Avengers 4 are vibranium based but
because Thor reignited the space Forge
once they fixed that little piece they
can just go back there and make as many
weapons as they need to and I almost
forgot there's a big question about
Thor's power if his people died the
directors explained that about half of
the Asgardians made it off the ship with
Korg in Valkyrie
so if Asgard is in a place it's a people
and Thor's power comes from his people
and they're still some as Guardians
around then technically it explains how
he still has his normal abilities so
hopefully that explains what's going on
with his character but now going into
phase 4 he's probably one of the most
powerful characters that they have and
it seems like Chris Hemsworth is totally
down to do this fun version of Thor that
you see with the Guardians so previously
I was saying that spider-man and Black
Panther were Marvel's two big a-list
characters big franchises going into
phase four but now just include Thor
into that mix they could still do Thor 4
and it would do really well but I'm just
hoping they choose to cross him over
with the guardians franchise again at
some point but what'll happen is is I'll
be posting my Westworld episode 3 video
next I'll name a new Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
that'll probably be on Monday there's
still plenty of stuff we need to talk
about but leave your requests in the
comments below while you wait for
everything click here for Black Panther
bloopers and deleted scenes and click
here for more new infinity war thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you